put a dress on your sister because we
bout to do that thing come on come with
me black
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm gonna come get that come touch daddy
why he come touch daddy he doing that
don't get dance
[Music]
I kind of ruined it there man I don't
have any rhythm I'm saying I ain't got
any rhythm but I'm gonna try I'm gonna
try to bring something for you today
welcome to this past weekend thank you
guys for being here with me and it is
Monday February to 6:00 in the year 2018
and you know what I'll say this man this
leap year some people don't want to
think it's sleepier guess what it is
leap year you ignoramus it's damn leap
year dude so do you have to pay rent
this month you ain't getting 30 days you
know I'm saying you could show it that
check a little if the landlord want to
take it up with somebody take it up with
the Lord you could take that up with the
Lord
oh this rents coming in about $38 light
well you could take that up with the
galactic powers okay momma didn't make
the hemispheres
you know I'm look I'm just balancing
this checkbook and it say that the
galaxy is short it means about 48 hours
of life this month so if you think I'm
paying you that full month rent that's
not a fact jack you make it an
assumption you're making an assumption
thank you guys for joining me on this on
this past weekend man some of them I
just gotta make sounds because you know
I'll tell you this episode I'll break it
down write down what's going on we're
gonna talk a little bit about we had a
caller calling about people's you know a
lot of people are doing this new you
know kind of this new body delicacy out
there where they eat Nast you know you
know snack on each others butts and
everything and I know that's you know
it's Monday morning maybe now people
don't want to listen about that or talk
about that but that's something that's
going on and is that a dark heart is
that not a dark art is that just mother
nature is that the way things are going
we're gonna discuss that briefly i'ma
get him to that Griffin man they had
that uh
that uh that Griffin Mike Perry fight
and if you guys saw that but that was a
real you know a real mail fiasco that
was a real mail fiasco man and I saw two
twins I grew up around two twins that
hated each other and man they would find
me they wanted to be the only one you
talk about a Last Man Standing match you
talk about a King of the Ring a Royal
Rumble that lasted I mean these dudes I
saw these boys for seven years and all
they did was fight beat the I mean try
to kill each other it was like that you
ever seen them in that old game show
called spy versus spy it was a like a
computer game video game that's what it
is
it was a video game and you had to you
know like little I think they were
muskrats or something and they were
dressed up in top hats and they did not
enjoy each other's company and they
would try to kill each other and that
was the whole video game and these these
uh the in these twins were like that and
that reminded me a little bit of you
know just watching these men out there
in this cage fighting then we're gonna
get in a little bit about we're gonna
talk about a little bit of news we got a
couple of news topics in you know a
little bit of life we're talking about
marriage relationships I went to the San
Bernadino fair or no San Fernando Valley
Fair this weekend so you know what I'm
saying vial offs I tapped into my
Nicaraguan roots tapped into my Latino
side I was out there bro you know yeah I
mean I saw some donkeys I saw the
world's smallest horse
I saw the world's smallest horse have
you seen him I have his name is Tom
Thumb and it's $2 to see him and I saw
that world's smallest horse and some
people saying you think you're like oh a
pony no not a pony you you idiot I'm
talking about the world's smallest horse
Tom Thumb and I made that investment
$2.00 and I saw him and so that's what
happened with my past weekend we're
about to get in to yours but one more
time let's hit that funky beat from this
came in from Brad Levine thank you
it's today baby it's the only today they
ever make it's the only today they make
is this one they're not making this one
again sometimes people say while I don't
ever have anything that's special you
know I don't ever have any rare Goods
will tell you got that you have today
that's the rarest good they make that's
the this the only thing that is it's as
original as can be it's really the only
original thing going on is today that's
it that's the only original thing going
on that's Brad Levine right there
sending that music a while back and I
love that beat and that thing you know
it gots me feeling I got my nuts kind of
tightened up and feeling wild and it's
got the you know I got my body feeling
good got my back back waxed last week
about his beautiful of polish girl and
man she ever you know some of those
hairs she pulls him like you're like
damn boy some of those things I think
they were hooked into my spine you know
just cure scoliosis they just ripped
that thing up and suddenly you you know
you're scurvy is healed up and I you
know and where I'm from I grew up where
you remember when they used to have the
thing at school where you would do the
scurvy test and they come over and they
get y'all in the line and they'd stand
you one after the other and then they
would bend you'd have to bend over and
then somebody would rub their hand and
when I really think about this it's
really I mean from a little bit it's
erotic but it's also very they wouldn't
allow this these days because
everybody's a real piece of but
they would somebody whoever the
instructor or somebody who knew about
scurvy or scoliosis would take their
hand and just rub it up your spine and I
remember as I got older as I had about
sixth grade did I think I might even you
know sprayed out once when they were
just testing me for scoliosis because I
was you know I had that there wasn't
much room between that ski
inside of me and whatever was going on
in the outside world you know I'm her
one time somebody scared me really bad
and I just came you know came on myself
because I've always had wild nerves and
heavy heavy nerves thick with nerves you
know I think if you looked inside of me
a lot of people have a lot of veins in
them and you know in a different you
know bones bone structure skeleton and I
know we're all operating on the same you
know the same running operating system
or the skeleton you know I know we all
the same basic template inside of us but
you know I think everybody's a little
different in there you know and I think
you know I've always had you know I've
always had small lungs and that's what
the doctor told me you know I had small
ribcage I had the rib that kind of the
the torso the inner torso the skeletal
torso of a large cat and I remember our
family met doctor telling me that when I
was young you know and I've always but
I've always you know I remember getting
scared once and just pick my you know my
penis and balls just kind of you know
just the jackal added in them up into my
pants and that was just you know that's
just me growing up and part of that is
growing pains and just being young and
feeling the vibrant energy of being
youthful but you know that I was always
right there was always just one quick
touch was gonna get me to pop off you
know some people it's that you know when
it comes to you know sex there's a lot
of different you know you know special
tactics and um common you know common
sutra' met you notes you know a lot of
you know foreplay or vibrant
their outdoors or whatever gets
you you know whatever get your marbles
to to spin but for me it was just I
needed a surprise moment and that's what
we really get me you know like if I was
a girl and she told me a ghost
story I'd come in a heartbeat and that's
just how I am you know that's how I
that's everybody's body reacts
differently to invited to the
environment but yeah I remember that
scoliosis test
and it was you know that thing was it
would turn you on a little bit because
first of all they have a couple ladies
come from the doctor you know or
whatever the doctor local hospital or
whatever and you didn't know these
ladies you know these were some fresh
ladies and yeah you're just a kid but
you're at that age it you know you know
like with with hidden perfidy it's like
when you hit poverty man you it's like
one day you're at school you're playing
soccer you know you're playing soccer
and you're wearing you know two tank
tops and uh I mean I remember for a
little bit when I was young you know my
mom got that used to sell hats
she got an you know my mother was a um
newspaper delivery woman and delivered
all types of stuff when I was growing up
she delivered cookies you know she
delivered um you know sales she was you
know just delivering you know small
things gas stations all of that they
used to have these news on wheels
magazines and you look through the
magazine and I got all the local trucks
and cars and you know a lot of
piece-of-shit vehicles you could get
anywhere from eight you know about $800
to maybe about you know $20,000 they had
everything in their boats
televisions televisions that could float
they had everything in the magazine and
on the front of the magazines that have
a hot chick laying out you know a piece
of tits out there and my mother would
take the magazines and deliver them out
and you know put them at all the gas
stations and the timesavers down in
Louisiana they used to have a they have
a place now it's called easy serve but
before that it used to be a place called
time-saver and in your neighborhood it
might be a kwik-e-mart or or a BP or
Conoco or it was just a fat one of the
gas stations that had they didn't just
have gas you know they were running on
for some some extras in there if you
went inside you could get some extras
you know you could get some band-aids if
somebody was bleeding so you could get
gas and heal your friend up you know you
could get some ointment some you know
special salve for your skin you could
get a frosty you know you could get one
of those snow cone kind of eye sees they
used to call them icy get an icy
and other people called him I don't know
what they called him in different cities
or towns but we call them bus they
called him icees and they had different
flavors you know coke coca cola they had
rum blue whatever the that one was
there that one just made your whole face
blue made everybody want to beat the
out of your breath because if you
had that blue mouth dude if you showed
up with that blue like the toughest dude
some time with eat oh I see or eat a
front of frizzy or whatever and he you
have all blue around his mouth and even
like look at this little right
here
this do it could be the toughest
dude it just put him in a different
mindset for Y all of a sudden you're
like I'll beat this I'll beat this
Azul right here I'll
beat this Smurf this dude look like even
you know eating Smurf ass and I'll beat
him right now and that was something
that uh but anyhow that was the gas
station you know in the gas station I
had a little bit you know these was gas
stations that I had a little bit extra
at him and he's were called time savers
man I can t remember we were talking
about Jesus okay we came in we're
talking about man
do you ever been lost before have you
ever been lost you know I'm seeing
you're like lost if you're in the
building you're like did I come in this
way or that way that's how it is man in
my head man when I start talking I'm
just I'm like I should have taken
bread crumbs you know through this
conversation because I don't know where
I'm at oh I know we're talking about
we're talking about purity hitting
puberty man because once you hit that
puberty man everything was different you
know you had one day where you go to
school and you're you know
oh my mother oh oh now I know cuz my
mother she also sold these hats and they
had you know this kind of I guess it was
a I don't know if it was after something
you know maybe it might have been Cinco
DeMayo or something but they had a big
you know uh they had a bunch of hats
people wanted Mexican hats sombreros
people wanted sombreros in sombrero
let's be honest dude it's a Mexican hat
we have to lie about it or pretend it's
not
and people wanted sombreros and so my
mother was delivering all these
sombreros and we used to wear some of
the my mom would have to give to
the gas stations or to sell at these gas
stations so a lot of times you see me at
school and I'm wearing these gas station
hats you know and it would say you know
if this if this trucks are rockin don't
come a-knockin and have like a big
18-wheeler cab on the front of it you
know or I'd have a t-shirt on that said
like Kenny Loggins or something some
kind of you know we're like a
bunch of just you know addressed in a
lot of gas station attire because my mom
would have extras because sometimes you
know in addition if she's already going
to these gas stations to deliver these
magazines other companies would come on
board and sometimes she would drop off
other stuff over there you know
different you know dude ads and whatnots
and whistles and who knows what
they even plugged to back armor we had
for a while
gunpowder somebody was trying to you
know start gunpowder back up anyhow so
you know I remember for a while my mama
had these sombreros and we had a you
know she had a extra case of sombreros
or whatever in the car and so we got
ahold of them and so next he know we're
wearing sombreros you know for a couple
months and it was also you know in
Louisiana it rains a lot so a nice hat
keep that water off your face you know
it's hard to think when waters running
down your face you know so that's uh
that's why a lot of people make poor
choices while they're drowning and it's
why a lot of people you know just you
don't see a lot of scientists working
outdoors you know in you know and you
know severe conditions is more of an
indoor sport science because it's hard
to think when you have the elements on
your skin on your face running across
your face water and anyway you know I'm
getting lost here but what I'm saying is
that we had these sombreros so we were
where the sombreros to school and I
remember what that you know there comes
a time when you hit that per body where
you are you go from dressing like
whatever wearing whatever wearing
sombreros extra backpacks anything to
the debt whenever you start to realize
that women are alive
and then next day boy you dude I
remember I remember we had these little
soaps that somebody had gotten from a
Howard Johnson motel did I remember the
first time I learned about deodorant I
didn't have any deodorant
I was still a kid and I was like
you know all these chicks no I don't
have deodorant so I would hold I would
put those little soaps hold them under
my arms all day so basically press my
arms against my ribcage and walk around
just all short-arm in it you know just I
mean dude I look like a Maitre D' that
had nothing to offer I look like a
waiter that had nothing for you you know
cuz I'm just walking around I have to
keep my arms by the side of my body at
least out of my elbows to hold the soap
under my arms and then you know my the
rest of my arm could come up but you
know it look like a penguin who was
trying to start you know I'm saying
like I just you know so the thing but
what I'm saying is once you hit that
parity you start flaring up and you
things change you know one day you're on
the playground you know look you lookin
to play soccer and the next day you look
you come to school and you lookin to
play your you know play your tongue
across some young nipples or in a
playground yard and that's nature
now and nowadays that would be
harassment you know nowadays soon
they're gonna make a kid's go being a
special cage when they go through per
Bertie
you know you sayin a kid can't you know
sprout out naturally because if
something's whoa what's happening to him
what's happening to him is he's he's you
know his body's morphing out you know
his body's Morphin out into a sexual
being and there's nothing wrong with it
and they soon they're gonna make you be
in a special cage they can have a
special cage at school or down at the
police office station because you know
going through per bird is gonna be a
crime watch going through per bird he's
gonna be a crime any why did me get
flared up about that but what I'm saying
is these ladies would come to school and
they would touch your spine and you
didn't know these ladies and you had
just gotten you know you would just I
mean when you start thinking about sex
you and you young you get that I mean
it's just like it's like you know
somebody just put a hit of acid and
you know inside of your dick and you you
know you your penis just start seeing
colors and thinking about the future and
that's what would happen man it's armor
and these ladies would come and check us
for scoliosis and I'd be erect man I'd
say I think I got it I'm like now you
don't have it I'll be like I think you
got to check again get Janet over here
to check at the same time I'm trying to
you know I'm saying I'm trying to get
this sixth grade three something going
I'm trying to have two ladies rubbing on
my spine at the same time but I remember
that was a crazy time and when you get
your back checked out at school and you
know you would know if you had scoliosis
or if you had some kind of spine
impingement but you know when you get
that back waxed I think this lady this
this lady pulled something out I mean it
just my posture has been better since
she took this one rib and they do these
little rips right around by your bait
right around by your panty line you know
right by that male panty line you know
where they they got that hair so
delicate right there my goodness it's
like what farmer grew these little you
know these little baby rabbits I mean
that hair right around your panty line
is so soft it's just such a softest hair
and it's almost dangerous to even have I
feel like but yeah so I got my back
waxed and and I'm feeling good you know
I shot was that yeah I'm feeling
stressed because I'm trying to not smoke
someone day two you know what I start to
hate is I've done this a million times a
million times I've been like I'm gonna
quit smoking and look I'm not smoking
all day like I will go all day and not
smoke and then the end of them the night
will come and I want to act out or do
something you know instead of doing
something that's really gonna get me
into trouble you know you know breaking
something out you know shooting out some
glass or something with a gun or
something like that or doing something
while you know throwing limes at you
know people in the park or whatever that
kind of I'll just smoke you know do
something I just want to do something
so I'll make it through the whole day
I'm good you know I mean in the past
four days I probably have four
cigarettes but yesterday I didn't have
any today I didn't have any so we'll see
man you know I kind of don't even feel
like bringing it up anymore cuz I'm just
tired of even saying it but my problem
is with smoking I can't enjoy it I would
smile I would just smoke ring hard to
have a cigarette at night if I wanted to
if I could enjoy it but that's where my
problem is my brain will not let me
enjoy a cigarette I mean my brain just
will not let me enjoy a cigarette my
brain wants to you know bother me about
it the whole time I'm smoking why
smoking man no why are you smoking dude
so I either no I would rather almost get
to a place where I can enjoy it once in
a while you know our forefathers used to
smoke you know the saying if you look at
old drawings and I remember I found
some drawings one time from probably in
the 1930s or something everybody in the
smoking so you know it was
probably fun because if you draw in
somebody and you're gonna take a whole
bit of extra time to draw them smoking
cigarettes I mean that's if you draw in
them having a pastime and taking that
time and actually draw that that seem
like they're probably you know they're
enjoying themselves maybe I went out to
the casino this weekend what else I was
out in the casino in out in Indio
California I want to thank some people
that came out this weekend some cool
cats came through man my boy Steven
some dude that look like my brother some
dude had oh this young lady came out
Jessica I think was her name and I'm
sorry if I got it wrong but she gave me
this one of these little like globe
things you could squeeze you know those
things that take stress off and she got
this is what she said to me she said
look you know I know you have a problem
sometime with the masturbation so
instead of and she goes instead of
touching yourself if you feel like you
got to squeeze something you could go
squeeze this I thought that that was
pretty funny that was nice of her but
yeah we had a nice a nice group
came out and and everybody had a blast
man
everybody had a blast we made the most
of it was you know casinos are different
because you know half the people are
there bought tickets because their fans
their friends they want to have fun that
you know they know you they're invested
in what's going on some of the people
are just been gambling and it can't take
it anymore you know some people are up
some people are down some men are out
there with hookers you know you got that
a little bit so we had a little bit of
everything and I like that I mean I
perform for hookers I'll perform for
anybody and so I feel like everybody
came through and had a good time out
there in Indio and I went to that fair I
went to a San Fernando Valley Fair and
I'm gonna make a I'm gonna put a video
up on patreon about it but if you
haven't been to the fair they had let me
tell you this they had the world's
smallest horse you know and so he was
there and they also had a petting zoo so
right there boy you know it's I mean
that petting zoo almost takes you back
to that scoliosis check you know you
touching him animals and you say man
this one you know he got a bent spine a
little this one need a few oranges over
here he's sneaking some vitamin C and
and giving it to him but they had
beautiful animals you know we saw we saw
two at we saw an animal this one animal
you know doing feces out of his buttocks
and it was I mean it was an exemplary it
was it was exemplary but that was a
blast man I went through there was out
there with Peter van a child skier Aldi
you know and and we got it done out
there in the desert I want to thank you
you beautiful freaks that came out you
beautiful freaks that came out I uh I
watch that max Griffin fight you know I
watch that max Griffin and Mike Perry
fight and first I noticed you know Mike
Perry six years younger than max Griffin
Max Payne Griffin and you got to think
that's kind of you don't think a lot of
times about age being up that a huge
factor but that means that max Griffin
has had us 365 for six years that's
two thousand more days of training that
max Griffin has had you know and I know
there's that you know you know there's
that other side of the coin where if
somebody gets too old they starts that
you know they start to deteriorate but I
think you're still on that
anterior rate were you still heading
uphill so he said 2000 more days to
Train to eat you know to try out
different vitamins you know to do
whatever he you know he's at two
thousand more days but you know this was
an exciting fight I think people were
excited not just this is the fourth
fight ever watch maybe your fifth fight
but you know they try to pull each
other's pants down at the UM at the body
ceremony because in the beginning you
know if you're new to BA MMA kickboxing
there is a body ceremony where they you
know they meet up and look at each
other's bodies and do the scale and
everything and Mike Perry try to pull on
the other man's pants and I thought it
was funny you know I watched it I just
thought it was funny you know cuz it is
nice to see something a little bit out
of the norm in this thing you know I
mean it's uh you know it's like Rome
it's like these are our gladiators and
sometimes you're one of your gladiators
it's gonna have more of a sense of humor
than the other or and also these men
respect each other just seem like a
funny thing to me some people you know
say different things about it but um but
I like the tattoos they had some good
tattoos both the men had some you know
make a squid jealous you know a lot of
hot ink out there you know you got your
boy Perry has that cross and goes into
some tribal work on his arms you got any
it says God's gift over his navel and I
don't know if that means he won you know
if you want a belly button contest or if
he's talking about his genitalia or what
but then the other man mr. uh max
Griffin
he has only god can judge me up here on
this clavicle he's got that clavicle
stamp you know that clamp stand and he
and I guess you know you know he only
wants God to judge him and that's what
he thinks but they but it ended up being
actually that the that the fight went to
decision so you know the judges actually
judged him and judged everybody but I
thought it was a good fight man
I mean I'll say this Mike Perry scares
me bro
he has that violent white dude in him
Mike Perry has that violent white dude
everybody knows this guy he's like you
ever been over to somebody's house if
you grew up in a poor neighborhood or
something you've been over to somebody's
house where they have a wild dog they
got a pit bull and when you get to the
gate you say do you put him up put him
up and they'll say oh he's up he's up no
he ain't up put him up and that's that
pit bull dog if somebody owns a pit bull
dog you make them put them up before you
come in the front gate and that's Mike
Perry he's that pit bull dog you just
don't know what he's gonna do you know
he's that while he's just you know he's
aggressive and he's energetic and you
just don't know what he's gonna do but
the fight was good man you know max
Griffin looked taller to me and I don't
know if it was some of the camera angles
they were using but max Griffin probably
look you know four inches taller to me
and he looked longer he got longer arms
and legs so I don't know who did the
height maybe they used different rulers
for the different heights but it seemed
like Max Payne Griffin had longer
extremities and it seemed like right out
of the gate I mean right out of the gate
you got Mike Perry comes in with a high
kick highest kick I saw him do the whole
time in it if max Griffin would have had
a hat on a top hat he would have kicked
it right off his head but he just missed
him and he came up with that a high kick
out of the gate and then Griffin of like
30 seconds into the fight Griffin his
pain and you could see he get that blood
in him he get that blood on on his head
and he starts that body lava starts to
flow out a little you know and uh and I
respect that you know Perry didn't touch
it some guy you know if you touch that
cut then you start to spread the blood
around you're just adding to you know
you're adding to that fiasco he didn't
touch it he just let it float just let
it drip drip - drop drop right out of
his uh brain cranium and you know I
respected that and he kept going I mean
he didn't even and I don't know if Perry
noticed it or not he was in such a zone
I mean when you're watching Mike Perry
fight man it's like it's almost like
he's fighting in a hallway if that makes
any sense
it's like he's he's just in this one
zone where max Griffin it's a little bit
more like you know like the lint like
he's like he's fighting with more of a
panoramic lens like he's you know a
little bit wider you know like he's kind
of seeing everything whereas Perry is
just so focused in and at the end of the
first round they go to the mat and this
is when I thought I was like oh man
Perry at the very end of the first round
Perry's on top of Griffin and I thought
if this thing goes 20 seconds more it
could be a wrap it could be a wrap I
like it could be a wrap because Perry
just is just so much propensity for
violence in him you just don't know
what's gonna happen you at any second
you didn't know what was gonna happen
with Perry you know he it's like it's
almost like a pack of matches you ever
put how to pack of matches in your
backpack and you see them in there and
you're like ah I should take these out
because who knows I'll put my backpack
down or set it somewhere I'll check it
checked luggage or something it could
start a fire at any moment
that's Mike Perry Mike Perry is match
he's he's a pack of matches in a check
bag you're like I don't know if I should
leave this in here because at any moment
it could start a fire Mike Pam I mean
he's just at any moment he's just he
should almost have a tattoo on the back
of this says flammable peligroso you
know just anything could happen with him
but his statement but his stance
everything you know he don't have that
long reach in his legs you know he got
them little you know he kicks kind of
like a um it's almost like a guy in a
wheelchair who likes to kick people you
know he can only kick so far because he
just have to he have that you know them
tiny kicks and I'm not saying the guy
wouldn't kick the out of me this
dude could kick my head off of my neck
and probably get a you know a
hole-in-one from a hundred and 170 yards
but he got them you know he got them
wheelchair kicks and then you got
Griffin out there and he I mean
this dude has he got ankles
how many ankles does Griffon have
because his legs I mean he got that it
look it's like he's got it's like he's
got ankles in his skin and he's got
360-degree ankles he didn't even have
knees it does seem like it big ankles in
the middle of his legs he just had that
much fluidity you know he's just that
fluid and then round and and went round
to stand when round to started you got
parry looks a little bit more he looked
a little winded I thought you know the
adrenaline kind of boils off there after
that first round and in the beginning of
the second round I feel like you can see
kind of what's starting to go on out
here you know you can see there's not
that like that crazy tension almost even
the fight even looks a little different
you know it just looks a little bit it
almost looks like there's some sweat on
the lens of the camera there's just you
know it's just a little bit more things
have kind of settled in a little bit
more and Perry has his coaches in his
corner the yelling form and it says you
know one of his lady you know he's got
his ladies his training partner and
she's ride-or-die if you've seen their
uh you know their YouTube channel I'll
put a link to it at the bottom of mine
in this in this episode but you know
this is ride-or-die lady they trained
together she could whup my ass this lady
called whoop some ass you know I feel
bad for their kids if they ever have
children the children misbehave somebody
getting their ass whoop but uh but that
you know you got the ladies and the
coaches over there and they're yelling
at Perry to get it you know get him
against the cage get him against the
cage but Griffin I mean he is he's just
so poised throughout that you can see
his plan like he has a plan the whole
time and you can't get him against
Griffin's like diarrhea you know and I
don't mean that he just you know you
don't know where he is you could you
know he's kind of bubbles up here he
bubbles up there and he's he's here he's
there he's there and then BAM he's the
and he'll knock you out and
that's kind of how it that's kind of how
it seemed he couldn't really contain him
and then BAM
he's the and he'll knock you out
and at the middle of the second round I
started to see him get a little bit
winded they're both starting to seem a
little bit winded and and Perry's
bleeding
I mean bleeding dude I'm talking second
day flow
blue is I mean it's heavy if I had this
I already be at the hospital if I had
even half of what is coming out of his
head a little bit I'd be at the hospital
so I commend him you know the guy's a
man I would be at the hospital you know
I don't already have probably filled out
a will I try to get my family members to
donate blood that's how I can't handle
that
and then Griffin brings him down with a
combo and and I thought that this could
be the end of it but the bell rings and
then went in and that's the end of the
second round for these guys and when the
bell rings you have to go do your own
thing for like a minute and I don't know
why they do that really but they just I
guess they want you to think about
what's just occurred and maybe if you
have some issues or some feelings you
want to get rid of or shed some you know
feelings or say something to a friend or
text a friend and you can do that but
then they are they come back out for the
third round and you start to feel like
Griffin has this one in the bag you know
you start to feel like Griffin has this
one in the bag at the start of the third
round they're both winded but then out
of nowhere
peri hits him with that snow globe er
and that snow globe er that's when
somebody hits you and suddenly you know
the weather changes and you don't know
what season it is for a second he just
hit him with that right beautiful and
suddenly it was a little bit of you know
it was a 30% chance of frickin uh of
cold dandruff and it might have been
Christmas Eve for max Griffin you don't
know for just a CD like whoa but it
wasn't that bad it wasn't that heavy it
was just it was just a Halloween hit you
know it was just uh you know just a
little bit of rain and some Halloween
but he still hit him with that snow
globe er and that's when and that's what
that that's Mike Perry
that's them you he's just those matches
you just don't know when he's gonna
strike or how quick it's gonna end and
at this point as the second half of his
third round goes on I'm like damn this
thing is a war this thing is a war Perry
climbs up him he climb up to the second
story of max Griffin he tried to come in
through the roof he trying to come in
through the roof of that man because
that's I mean Perry's plan you could see
it was it's just to win and this look
anything about fights you know
but I know how to watch and sin and
talk about what I see and parry like it
just seemed like his plan win the fight
that's the whole plan whereas it seemed
like Griffin he has more other little
plans you know move this way
you know do the stanky leg you know like
he had a lot of different little plans
put in there wear him down do this do
that
whereas Griffin it's just like man dude
I was nervous the whole I was nervous
the whole fight and if that's what Harry
does man he just for some reason for me
personally watching and he makes me
nervous and I but I thought in any
moment moment in that last minute I
thought Perry could have won it because
Perry has this thing he'll do anything
to win he'll do anything to win and that
that's just who he is he will do
anything to win and there's nothing you
can do about it and at the very end you
could start to see where was really
getting even and I think if that fight
would have gone another 45 seconds I
wouldn't be surprised if Mike Perry rips
off one of his own arms and just beats
max Griffin to death with it
that's what I would not have been
surprised because it was just I gotta
win this fight and you know I love the
fact that his hometown was on you know
his home a home state of Florida there
was a lot of respect there in the
audience for him you know and that's
platinum Mike Perry and he's gonna be
back he's gonna be back I would watch
him fight a million more times you know
I think you know I'm not gonna tell him
what to do cuz I don't know anything you
know I was into fights when I was young
and both times I pretty much got my ass
beat I think one time I think I might
have might have got some licks in or at
least you know kind of caught this dude
hard in the neck one time right there on
that on that sugar shelf right there on
that Lyons lick but anyhow man I'd watch
these dudes fight again in a heartbeat
great fight great fight great fight
speaking of great things this episode
brought to you by grey block pizza and
you can always get them and they're down
here and they also have bronx-born pizza
and that's now up in Bend Oregon that
I'll be opening soon so if you live up
and Bend and you need a good job and
you're a good employee and you're a good
person
go stop
Greylock go stop up in there and
bronx-born pizza and see what they're
doing and see what's going on what else
I got some new dates are gonna be added
soon to the calendar Calgary Chicago
those are coming on soon I'm gonna let
you know right now that I will be at the
let me see I'll be in New Orleans
actually next weekend for a buddy's
wedding they don't be in Tacoma at the
Tacoma comedy club the 15th and 16th of
March the 17th I'll be in Spokane I'll
be at levity live in Oxnard
March 23rd through 25th and then April
20th and 21st I will be in New Jersey
and Hasbrouck Heights at bananas comedy
club so some good stuff going on there
you know and I'll get you this Calgary
in Chicago dates are not locked yet but
they'll be coming soon oh and I'll be in
Tampa I'll be in temp as well and
that'll be April 6th and 7th there in
Tampa and Tampa Florida at Rock Brothers
brewing at the attic that's what it's
called in all those places are available
in theof on comm slash tour tio tio you
are what else ma'am you know had some
final thoughts on on the Florida
shooting you know in the tragedy I'm
sorry to even call it a shooting you
know it's uh it's sad that that that's
how it's even how I even say it you know
but the tragedy in Florida I've just
been thinking a lot about it and you
know everybody cuz I don't like it is
only just like seeing all the argument
after all the argument of people all you
know a lot of you know Monday Morning
Quarterback sitting on their couches
saying what should what shouldn't what
we should do what should you know and I
thought maybe you let the parents vote
you know you let the parents who have
been affected by this who have had this
happen
you know who have had children affected
by this you let them vote on what do
they think would be most helpful because
how do we know I mean we can have an
idea you know I have my own ideas you
have your own ideas your own thoughts
your own suggestions as of what could be
more helpful
people want stricter gun laws
some of it you know some of it the
problem with a lot of laws is people
find loopholes you know it's like you
know the young fella that got the gun
apparently he bought a rifle but you
know they have they have these
high-powered guns these AR 15s or
whatever
assault rifles or whatever and they're
classified under rifle so it's like
because when you know when their law was
made people are thinking rifle you know
I'm saying that thing where you see a
pheasant 600 miles away he trying to pop
him off but then they changed the name
of guns they put a certain name they
find a loophole or whatever I mean
bottom line is nobody wants this kid to
have this gun nobody does nobody does
nobody wants this kid to have this gun
you know to have this weapon to have
this pain have this whatever makes him
hurt or be detached nobody wants this
kid to have this but I was just thinking
maybe so that everybody isn't yelling
you know you let the people who were
affected by it make you know dude then
they make a law maybe in their state
they get to vote on the law on what the
thing is that because they are the ones
who are affected by it and maybe with
that I mean it's such a small condolence
but there would be some sense of it
would provide them I'm not gonna say a
sense of closure because I'm not saying
that that even equates to closure but it
would provide them at least some sense
of having a say-so
in how maybe this doesn't happen in the
future so there's a thought that I had
you know maybe let the families do it
you know and then also thought maybe you
know for me it's like I think a lot
about that parents can't they can't
discipline their children anymore you
know a lot of parents yeah they whoop
their kids or spanked them but they
didn't a lot of parents weren't beating
their kids now you know I hear from a
lot of my friends at have children it's
like they say anything they're the kids
next thing you know the kids are
threatening you know child child abuse
all of this and so it's just you know
there's no discipline so I wonder where
does that you know where does that come
into effect where there's no discipline
at all
or there's no like a parent can't feel
like that they could you know physically
discipline their kid I'm not saying
there's an answer there but it make me
think you know I remember even my old
ass daddy do it at 80 years old
that man would chase me around with the
belt and if he didn't do it my
mother did it and I got my ass whooped
20 times dude I was afraid of my friends
daddies remember that that was the
craziest thing you'd meet your friend
like damn and I like Brandon but his
daddy bro and your do your
friend's daddy was kind of a little bit
allowed to beat your ass if you were
stretching out you know you were
stretching out and being wild that man
was allowed to hook you up with at least
one pop nothing heavy but at least one
then I remember I was walking me and my
buddy was soaking wet one time you know
for nothing crazy probably just you know
he had one of those deep ass bird baths
and we were poor so we'd get up in that
you know and we try to lay there
quiet enough in that bird bath armor one
time and we'd lay in there and he had
you know we'd get some fruits or
something like that or a couple of
little couple sex and planners peanuts
and laying that birdbath and kind of put
the peanuts up I like our chests where
our chests would stick out of the water
and the birds we try to get the birds to
come down and get them and be real still
and quiet and then when the birds would
get on us try and grab the bird you know
and there's just a little something that
we did to kind of pass the time and
stuff when it wasn't too hot out and
when that water didn't have mosquitos in
it sometimes those bird baths and when
at some point that thing is just a womb
for mosquitoes there ain't no
bird stopping by that you know I
think it's just like a diseased rumata
where they ain't changing the bedsheets
that's all that bird bath is and you
would see that and you see no birds
coming and that's when you know you got
to wash it out and clean it out but we
get in there and I run one time we came
back in the house dripping wet and he
walked by his mom and she was pet he
kind of walked by quickly by his mom she
was pissed
we were dripping water on her clean
floor and I came by second and I got I
got his ass whoopin I got his ass what
but it was supposed to be for him but I
got it man I got I mean she snowglobe me
dude suddenly it was Easter I
don't care if it was November third pop
pop it was Easter you know it was
Easter and there was a 60% chance of
lightning and uh and and I
remember that's just how it happened
when he was a kid he knows somebody cool
kind of Whoopie and I wonder if that
kind of happens sometimes with kids but
nobody you know parents can't be they
not beat them you know I used that term
because it's you know maybe it's a
humorous way to kind of you know he got
his ass beat but but to get whooped to
get some discipline I mean animals you
know people always say we should be more
like animals
hamsters will eat their children
if shit's getting wild a lot of animals
beat their kids you know if you leave a
wooden spoon out in the woods and you
come back the next day there will be a
mother animal somewhere whoopin one of
her kids ass with it and probably
deservedly so alright let's take some
calls man let's take a couple of calls
that came in this week some wild ones
this past weekend
okay let's hit this hot line right here
bang bang hey what's up Theo this is
Ryan burns if you're in Pleasanton Cali
what's up Ryan burns up there in
Pleasanton CA and I never been to
Pleasanton but that's it better be a
decent place where that's false
advertising okay let's hear more on word
pending on eatin ass dude
you know you ever yeah whoa man you know
to say it twice like that in a row you
know it's already I heard you the first
time when you did ask and uh Oh nervous
to hear l'amour this Kaulitz hear
l'amour do your eatin see what
you were what your schedule is with that
man man that's a wild thing to ask
somebody I feel like is that the
weirdest thing that has somebody these
days if you eatin ass out there you know
look man I'll say this man I'll have a
little you know have a little I ain't
having a lot you know I ain't having a
lot of eatin ass they didn't have it
when I was a kid you didn't have that
that wasn't a thing you know you could
do they had you know you'd do a little
bitter maybe you try a little bit of
butt sex or something fancy with your
thumb every now and then you know I'm
saying you know you try to drop off that
inner hitchhiker but you ain't uh you
ain't you wouldn't eaten it and now that
things a little bit more edible these
days and I think it's because they have
stronger antibiotics and stuff these
days you know and but I mean that's I
mean that's pinkeye country you know
it's dangerous a little bit so I think
if somebody showered up I'll have a
little bit of it you know I but you know
you also got a monitor you know you
gotta stay on your side of the gate you
can't go licking on the other side of
the fence bro cuz that's lunchtime and
you got a G up and tighten up and you
see you got to be careful you know so I
think it's it's definitely a you almost
it's pretty French really to do it I
mean you got a back pretty French you
got to be pretty fancy down there if you
eat an ass you can't be all in there
with your teeth out and stuff that's
that's dangerous man you're gonna
get sick so I'll have a little you know
I mean that's one thing I'll worry
about relapse and I'm a year-and-a-half
sober but if a lady shows up with a you
know a beautiful butthole in the eight
ball I mean that's my worst that's my
that's my greatest fear and my worst
fear cuz that thing I'll take you out
boy that magical wink that thing will
take you out you know that thing will
take you out but I you know so I'll have
a little pins on a season two you know I
ain't eating that thing in a summer bruh
I ain't eating that thing in a summer
you know but I might have a you know I
might have a little snack or you know
mill around that odor of table you know
some September late September it's
through maybe January let's get on man
let's get a uh let's get into another
call here but thank you for calling
there brother let's get into another
call here here we go yo New York
what's up Geo from New York and I'm
gonna add me in New York date I don't
know when it's gonna be just yet but I'm
gonna add one before I get over there in
New Jersey maybe let's hear more thank
you for calling Geo onward I'm just
calling with a question for God in
marriage growing up I was the oldest of
eight kids you know I changed the
shitload of diapers in my life damn
oldest of eight kids that's a lot that's
a lot of womb man your mother's giving
out a you know that's a lot of womb work
so you know much luck to your mother
given birth date eight children homework
no I never really wanted children
growing up but I got one on the way and
I'm gonna be a man and do what I got to
do
Wow you got one on the way huh
congratulations dude that's awesome
right that's a blessing you know it's a
blessing you know be able to you know
have a healthy child in and uh let's
hear more to uh raise raise the baby you
know I had a good father I was a good
mother out of your childhood and can't
complain but now this girl that I'm with
we've been together a few years now
she's always talked about she wanted to
get married you know marry them marriage
is something that I never really saw a
benefit to you know I never knew what
was the reason behind getting out yeah
you love each other you get married I
love you you love me
we both know we love each other and
what benefit is getting married in urdu
for us you know like okay so that's what
you are know what benefit is getting
married gonna do for you
okay you both love each other homeward I
mean we're gonna spend all this money on
I'm gonna spend the money on the ring
we're gonna spend money on a wedding you
know and you know my parents divorce
their parents a divorce and I no more
failed marriages in my life than I do
successful ones maybe I don't know if I
should pop the question just to make her
happy
and then one we're gonna get the
government involved okay
and I appreciate that comment there's a
lot of good points in this you know you
asked what benefit you know and the
interesting thing for me is just about
listening you kind of named one of the
benefits a little bit you know I'm
assuming you said your parents you know
you say you had a good father and I'm
guessing that maybe your parents were
married and that's just a guess you know
so eight children I mean I don't see how
you just I would I'm gonna go ahead and
assume they were married cuz excuse me
eight children you get married yeah
that's a lot of children you know that's
that's I'm gonna held us damn barn work
I mean us in some countries bro y'all
could be sold off as a group for for
food you know for y'all could be
auctioned off in some places but that
many offspring but what I'm saying is
this it sounds like you benefited from
it so that's you know it's kind of one
it's a little bit of an answer for you
just answering your own thing you asked
why and you you know and then the first
thing you mentioned was money you know
the costs the costs of things and we do
that now and it's you know that's no
fault of yours that's how we are
everything everything is about it's all
about a cost these days you know what
you know I got to pay for the way the
ring the cost and you know I was talking
there's a girl that I've been spending
time with that you know and and we were
talking about this sort of thing and
just talking about relationships and I
was talking to one of my good friends
about this the other day and and one of
the reasons I think is so that it adds
some it makes it real that's the thing
you know it makes it real if you got to
get a prenuptial agreement or whatever
you worried about some of that
are you worried about the cost of the
ring tell your lady look you know I'm
gonna get you a nice ring now and I'm
gonna get you a nicer ring down there
you know we're talk to her about it
share your fears but I think for I think
because in it then you put some skin in
the game you know if you're just like
let's just see how it goes then you
could always leave she could always
leave how much love it how deep is your
love gonna be able to get if you don't
if you if that if one foot could always
be out the door and I'm not saying that
in an accusatory way but I know this
that if I don't if I'm not probably tied
into something will I be able to make
you know am I gonna commit to it as much
I don't know you know I don't know and I
think that's what it is just ties you it
ties you to the fire a little it just it
ties you to the fire and then the kid
growing up does it matter my parents are
married my parents weren't married I
don't I think it does you know I was put
on Twitter the other day man that you
know I think they would have a law that
subsidizes to dual parent working family
to dual parent working families if both
parents have to work let's subsidize the
family because I think one of the
biggest problems in our country is that
there's just not a family anymore
you know a kid goes home and it's
nobody's heir and then they just make
their own choices or you know we're all
just we're getting separate from each
other even as a family and that's the
scary part because you can get separate
as a you know as a group as a country is
this in that but when you start in that
household when there's nothing mayor
that nucleus when that thing is running
astray you know if you don't care about
your family if we don't even build that
then what do we have so look it's
definitely brave these days you're going
against the grain but it sounds like
you're coming from an educated place
you're already thinking about these
things why a marriage what makes it
important and that's a good question man
we're gonna get some more callers are
gonna call in about this and I'm gonna
try to do a Thursday episode on it you
know I had a buddy who um who I spoke
with the other day and we actually he
sent in a text and I want to read that
message
that came in from him right here it said
Theo to follow up on our conversation
earlier this week I'm filing for divorce
from my wife after seven years of
marriage pretty damn scary but have been
so unhappy in the relationship for the
past several years and tried to convince
myself that it was best for our young
child to suck it up
I truly gave it all I had but finally
realized life was just too short to not
be happy coming from the south I don't
have tons of friends who have gone
through divorce that I can reach out to
but know that the percentage is high and
even at like 50% I was hoping to get
some positive stories from your
listeners about life after divorce
especially when involving a child
regaining one's identity finding love
again being a single parent etc really
appreciate it man
and here's to finally getting some BJ's
again gang gang well and I appreciate
that that text that came in and yeah I
can imagine man you know I know that my
buddy's going through some of this and
you know I know that this person that I
spoke with is going through some of this
and you know those were obviously a lot
of his concerns and that's man I can't
imagine but these things that make me
scared to get into it you know with what
make me scared about getting a
relationship I wrote some of it down my
fears I'll tell you my fears right now
but if you guys have some thoughts for
either one of those gentleman right
there you know you can hit the hotline
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three and we can drop some of those
in regarding this scenario and in this
situation why marriage and then once you
get divorced as a single parent you know
if you have any real tips for navigating
that and that that first got to
be exciting a little bit you know it's
got to be a little bit like you know
like you get an extra fourth of July in
the year but here's some of my fears
when I was thinking about it you know
marriage scares me you know because you
got to stay there you know it's like
being in an elevator and the elevator
breaks and you're in there with somebody
and you're like
you got to stay there until it gets
fixed you know and that's how I
sometimes I that's just a fear I have
I'm not saying that's what marriage is
like but it's a fear that I have you
know it's just a fear of lack of you
know probably just having it just just
commit and be and just get through the
tough times and you know it's it's a
it's just a fear that I have you know
and also I think there's a fear of I
think every man probably has a fear of
not being able to you know finagle with
another woman or touch another woman's
crotch or you know just those sex
thoughts that come in come into your
brain you know touch some woman's you
know butthole or something down in like
a ruber somewhere in some fancy location
you know those are the things you have
in your head like in my head it's like
oh man I don't get married so you know
what if I run into some hot chick you
know over at the you know down in
Pensacola and she wants me to touch her
butthole for a second well the truth is
that's probably not gonna happen but
there's some weird thing inside of my
head or inside of men's head sometimes
that it just it puts this weird outlier
out there in our thoughts and then we
just you know it's it's uneven
you know and then we don't act on the
good possibilities in front of us
because we have these weird things that
we think might happen that probably
never will and even if it does what the
I'm just touching someone's
somebody's butt in Florida for a minute
and then what then I'm lonely then I'm
still sitting out at the beach or trying
to get it uber or something I'm just
back to being lonely but those are
something you know there's some fears
that I wrote what else did I have
oh I fit what if I up you know in a
relationship or in a marriage and I
cheat or I stray or I you know do porn I
look at pornography you know and that's
part of my marital you know agreement
and so that's scary to me because it's
like you know you make this agreement
you make this commitment you want you
know you want to be able to honor it and
you want them not
honor it you know so that's these are
just my fears I'm trying to go through
my fears Oh sharing a bathroom that's a
fear I have about getting married did I
haven't shared a bathroom since college
bruh honestly and that was hell you know
that was hell man
and I just that's my biggest fear it's
coming home and seeing some you know a
couple couple straight turds of
something in the toilet and they ain't
mine
Anna's ship makes me scared bro you know
and that may seem crazy but that
makes me scared dude
I don't to see somebody else's
straight-up turds and I don't want
somebody to see my turds you know I
don't know that sounds crazy brother it
might sound stupid but I just it makes
me scared man I see somebody else's
turds bro I might be out sayonara dude
and I know that's something wrong with
me I know it's not you know something's
wrong with me but I'm just
saying these are some I've just weird
fears that I have and then I think one
of my biggest fears is probably just
that you know that I don't want to
create probably the same you know like
create a childhood for a child that's
similar to my childhood you know that I
guess I would fear that I create like a
shitty childhood for a kid and I think
that maybe that's sometimes I can't
access that fear as much but I
definitely think about that and I
definitely think about that as being you
know probably something inside of me
that you know probably scares me a lot
and now some shitty childhood is good
you know I think I just don't want to I
wouldn't want to create a childhood
where kid feels unloved
because shitty look I don't care if that
kid you know if he's got two tank tops
and a wintersun gang gang brother you're
living you know if he made if we eaten
macaroni 361 days he here boy then
that's what we that's okay I don't care
if we have a you know there's struggle
but I don't want you know just to
up somehow and create our environment
where a kid feels on love
so I think that those are some of my
fears now so my excitement I was think
about this whole my excitements when it
comes to you know marriage and
relationship would be coming home and
having a loving family in the house you
know and coming home and having like a
loving family you know that I'm welcome
to be a part of you know and it's not
like you come in and you start hugging
people and people like who the are
you you know like you're something that
broke into somebody's house it's like a
family that your own family and they
care about you and everything and you're
allowed to come inside him and love them
so that's a that's some excitement also
I was talking to some friends about this
this week you know and I was and one of
my buddies was saying you know don't
future trip you know try not to future
trip sometimes but not think about those
sorts of things I'll put off you know I
stack everything into the equation like
okay you know I got you know like if I
you know first uh you know I get married
and then it's net you know like then I
start thinking well what if you know now
I got a family now I got a house and you
know what if there's a divorce and what
if there's and next thing you know I'm
it's forty years later and I'm out on
like a catamaran living in a you
know marina or something because it's
all I got left because all my money's
with the wife and the children you know
and and and then it's just as crazy so
you know I'm out there looking for you
know maybe research and looking for
treasure and this stupid you know
buying metal of the detectors and stuff
and the truth is that you know none that
not even the first thing has happened
but already I've taken myself out of a
you know possibly doing something
because I'm future tripping so much and
that's something that's gonna you know
that that I noticed some time that I'll
do and another another thing about
another thing I was singing about is uh
and another thing I've seen about is
when it come to finding somebody who's
just you know try not to be too picky
you know I start to notice that with my
friends we have so much access and
everything to
you know to other people and and so much
you know and when you have access to
other people and you see so many other
people and how other people look and
everything with so much advertisement in
in magazines and videos and everything
you're more likely to compare kind of
what's in front of you to all these
other sensationalized and heightened
things and we just gotta you know I know
that I know that I got to be careful
about that kind of stuff because the
truth is if they don't fund judging
somebody on you know something little
didn't trust me I know I'm showing up
with nine little things nobody got more
little things wrong with them and than
me so those are some things I guess that
I've been thinking about when it comes
to like you know marriages and
relationships we've got a couple more
calls that came in here so I'm going to
uh I'm gonna get into some of those
right now here we go hey Hannah from
Orange County
let's hear more well it definitely
sounds unfortunate for you but if I'm
that dude that sounds awesome let's hear
more make a living as well as the man
the household really haven't been ok I
appreciate that thanks for the put a
question what do I think about that the
household duties haven't been split up
equally well I don't think that both
parents should have to work you know
ideally so be nice and I know that
that's just you're like well Theo that's
a pipe dream both parents have to work
you know that's the actuality well yeah
that is probably the x-value but I think
it'd be probably better you know if you
get to like if you're talking about a
real household where you have children
where you could get to a point where
maybe somebody doesn't have to even if
you're making less money I mean it might
be tougher to survive
and I'm coming from a place where I
don't know you know I haven't had that
experience yet but as far as dividing
them up you know I think you somebody
got to doing you know maybe you take
some turns you know I find that if you
know if like if we get hellofresh or
something like that and make that
together for dinner that's usually
pretty fun far as um you know laundering
and stuff like that I like the smell of
downy softener you know and I like the
little bear that's on there um what is
that downy bear's name let me look that
downy softener bear I think they have
different one for different countries I
think the Mexican one is a bear it's not
know Umberto I think downy softener
softener bear name let me see what his
name was
the Snuggle Bear sorry his name's
snuggle bear' and I think they have
depth like in you know in different ones
you get different countries you get
different names but I like the smuggle
bear so I don't mind doing a little bit
of laundry you know but as far as
dividing them up yeah I think that's
just different in different households
you know some people will love being a
homemaker and some people love going out
to work if both y'all like to work then
I think at that point you probably
hopefully have a little bit extra money
we could hire somebody to do some of
that home making do your laundry you
know all I get my lawn because when you
do that you're creating a job for
somebody else - I like my laundry I like
to fold my up into different shapes
you know I like to do that um you know
fold a shirt up into a Swan if I
can and there's different YouTube videos
you can watch learn how to do all of
that so I guess you know I like that
sort of thing but yeah there's no big
rules dividing up household duties but
at least now there's no rules I'm sure
back in the day women felt like they had
to do it you know I know that probably
like in the 50s and 60s men were out
there you know going to work and drink
it and just drunk driving that's pretty
much men's responsibilities and then
women were you know taking care of the
family and taking care of the home but I
think it'd be nice if we could find I
don't care what parents at home but if
somebody could be at home to help out
more and maybe that's a luxury these
days but how do we get to the point
where it's
or that's a looked like it just seems
crazy and maybe I don't know
historically what happened but how do we
get to the point where somebody
everybody has to work like what
what happened
maybe I'm ignorant I must be because I
don't know the answer to that what else
let's take one more call right here here
we go
hey my name is Kevin I'm calling him
because I feel like I'm being forced to
practice the dark arts in my
relationship and I don't really know
what to do all right tell us more Kevin
thanks for calling basically what's
going on is we've been wanting to date
this girl for years and sounds a little
stalkery but also just sounds maybe
hopeful let's hear more spheres she told
me that she had genital herpes and
really aside from that we've had like a
couple ups and downs in the past but I
still know I want to be with her we
recently started dating we're both in
our 20s and she's really attractive and
she's amazing with my daughter and okay
so you got this lady she got that gah
she got that genital herpes and look
they say I read somewhere that 70% of
people have general herpes and they
don't even know it I mean also could
have just been my friend of mine wrote
that on a piece of paper and sent it to
me but I did read that somewhere
but I mean look man some people don't
even know they have it you know I had a
buddy his neck used to get all speckled
out and he said he had freckles and I'm
like dude you don't have freckles but
you have herpes dude freckles are like
little bitty spots on your face they
look like cinnamon a little bit like
somebody you know kind of beat you with
a hard cinnamon or beat you with like a
sack of cinnamon in the face I said you
got herpes bro because some ice have one
but he's just wear a scarf around his
neck full year he used a 365 day a year
scarf and he was just hot in herpes but
he didn't know he did any medicine so
these things would get flared up you
take that scarf off and it would just
smell strong smell like somebody was
just you know building a cheese somebody
just making a case of dip behind his
scarf and so you got to be careful but
uh what do you do let's hear a little
bit more on this one oh absolutely
okay so she loves your family she fits
in
she's got that g8 yellow already Dayton
what's the issue only thing is I've
noticed in the past two months that
we've been dating is that she really
doesn't have any sex drive when we do
have sex it's like we may be born so we
get that and even when we do it actually
comes within five minutes of rolls over
and says yeah we're done
oh that's my old trick right there let's
hear more so I don't even get mine I
have a super high sex drive and since
she never once had sex
I found myself visiting the dark arts
and master dating pretty much every day
sometimes even two to three times a day
man that's that's wild two to three
times a day man that's like an it's like
a eighth of a cup bra what's going on
man
I appreciate you calling man I feel your
pain on this let's hear more she told me
in the past
she thinks watching porn and
masturbating is like a form of cheating
fair and honestly I love this woman and
every part of our relationship is
amazing aside from this one thing so I
you know leaving or really isn't an
option okay and it isn't an option for
me hey
okay so leaving her isn't an option you
got the she you know she'd come as she's
showing up with that genital herpes and
everybody brings some kind of baggage to
the situation you know some people
horders you know some people you know
afraid of the dark you know i sedated
girl we had to keep all the lights on in
the house so I'd have to wear like a
dark mask and everything while stomach
sleep and some people got herpes people
got stuff you know that's mother nature
but you know her sex drive is low she
doesn't want to have any sex really your
sex drive is high and I think you just
got to talk about it I think just talk
to her about it what does she think some
because here's the thing if she doesn't
it she doesn't feel like maybe sex she
should at least have some recommendation
for you on how you can feel okay you
know you got to at least probably try
and communicate about it because you
know you know that's what it is is what
communicating and maybe so maybe just
talk to her about it I think that's you
know you're asking me I would just say
ask her what does she think because you
can't be jerking off two or three times
a day man especially if you got a kid
I mean dude you got a kid running around
and three times a day that's for
probably probably 15 minutes a day I
mean you're just as crazy bro you got a
child and you're out there hanging out
in the driveway hiding in a back seat or
whatever you know it parked around the
corner touching yourself get your life
together man you know sound like you got
a decent lady there she just obviously
she's fighting when I have sex cuz she's
gotten herpes bro you thought about that
maybe you know if somebody got herpes
and from sex they probably I kinda want
to have any more sex so maybe they but
you know obviously she won when it comes
to sex she probably did wait you know
which could be safely done so I don't
know you know I don't know what the
solution is but I think just talked to
her about it say you want a little bit
extra activity maybe just see if she'll
sit up and watch you masturbate you know
that's kind of a Polish trick but as
something people do you know that's kind
of a you know that a little bit of you
know it's like a peeping tom but both
y'all know each other so you could do
something sexy like that or put on a
nice outfit and you know maybe she ha I
don't know maybe have her go outside and
look in the window and watch you
masturbate
some people get off on the weird stuff
like that that makes people feel excited
you know or kind of mysterious or
something so those are just a couple
ideas you know if you guys got any
answers for some of these cats and hit
this hotline you can let me know nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three I got some big news I got some big
news
but I'm not going to share Papa till
next week because I just want to make
sure that everything is cool we've got
to get this Agreement to go through and
stuff but I'm excited and I want to
thank you guys for your support for
checking out this past weekend and yeah
everybody that came out in India
everybody they came out in Portland
everybody that came out that's gonna
come out in Tacoma and Spokane and
everywhere everything's you know just
really appreciating the love and support
I will be on I'm gonna be on a big
podcast tomorrow or tonight whenever you
watch this it'll be tonight I'm not
gonna tell you which one probably but
you'll know you'll know but hit the
hotline if you got some suggestions for
any of these people nine eighty five six
six four nine five zero three for any of
our callers or textures that texted in
you know we had we had the one gentleman
that texted in and said he we had the
one gentleman that texted in you know
who's going through the divorce what's
it going to be like any suggestions for
him as a new divorced parent with a
child we had the the guy that texted my
be married at all and then we had this
this person had just hit in about the
you know the herpes in the household and
masturbating three times a day and
hiding from his own wife and child or
child but uh but thank you guys for your
support I'm gonna get something to eat
and I got some auditions tomorrow I got
a freaking practice for so but I love
you man be good to yourselves you
probably deserve it
[Music]
celebrate